now let's check back in with rocky at
tivoli village she's getting a taste of
their newest sweet spot
they are putting me to work here at milk
cow london was my first customer ever
how did i do
uh
you know you know i saw you hesitate a
little bit but i believe you london
thank you see look he's still eating it
i must have did a good job he ordered
the milky honey but now we have another
order here with chelsea someone ordered
the dirty boba
okay so chelsea what goes into the dirty
boba so we already lined the cup with
brown sugar and boba and then obviously
with the soft serve and then we're gonna
just gonna top it off with more boba and
brown sugar now while i do this just
explain the cons what is boba for
anybody out there who doesn't know um
because it's so good so boba is tapioca
pearls they have some kind of chewy
texture they add something fun to your
creation i love that and that's what's
so fun about milk cow is you guys can
also customize your orders this one's
pre-made but people can customize too
right
what are what are some of the things
they can do to customize um we have
toppings like honey cube and then we
also have fruits diced fruits and then
syrups
perfect and then of course classic
oh my gosh this honestly it's not great
you're obviously the expert but i think
it's good
where's the spoon
so while we look for a spoon chelsea
tell us about the other things on the
menu that people can order um so we
obviously have the staff servers which
are our most famous and then we also
have other drinks that include the
software such as the ice cream tea and
the floats and the milkshakes but then
for those who don't enjoy soft serve as
much
they can grab a toy towards the fruit
teas and then we also have non-dairy
options as well there's my spoon
i was gonna go for this spoon here but
we got a spoon okay so and then for
people who
um are coming in trying to order
something new trying to try something
new for the summer there is a discount
right here at the tivoli village
location on the instagram at milpow mv
you can find the 10
discount off your order until the end of
this month that is cool and for you you
know back here making these things how
fun is it for you guys how creative can
you get it's really a fun project
there's new combinations people come in
with new ideas and stuff and
they look
cool and enjoyable cool and enjoyable
yeah that's exactly what this is thank
you chelsea come on send it back to you
guys so good
tipley village come through